conseil de sécurité de l'onu ce jeudi à
new york et à la fiche dialogue de
sourds entre russes et occidentaux
chers collègues j'espère que vous saurez
résister à la tentation de jouer devant
les caméras et que vous ne ferez pas de
notre réunion un cirque que vous ne
présenteraient pas ici des accusations
sans fondement disons que la russie va
attaquer l'ukraine
rappelez-vous alors que la russie a à
plusieurs reprises tourné en dérision
nos avertissements et nos alertes en
mélodrame et en un sens ils ont
régulièrement amassé plus de cent
cinquante mille soldats aux frontière
ukrainienne et ont donc la capacité de
mener un assaut militaire massif selon
moscou ces soldats ont en partie été
déplacés vers des casernes éloignée de
la frontière pour preuve le kremlin
diffuse ces images de train chargé
d'équipements militaires le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky n'y voit
lui que des manoeuvres plus tôt dans la
journée le président américain joe biden
a également remis en cause la version
russe
ils n'ont retiré aucune troupe
premièrement ils ont amené des troupes
supplémentaires deuxièmement nous avons
des raisons de croire qu'ils sont
engagés dans une opération sous un faux
prétexte leur donnant une excuse pour y
aller toutes les informations nous
disent qu'ils sont prêts à entrer et à
attaquer licra d
une diplomatie au point mort mais qui
n'abdique pas anthony blinken a proposé
à son homologue russe des affaires
étrangères une rencontre en europe la
semaine prochaine si la russie n'envahit
pas l'ukraine